people put in prenups what's called
Fidelity Clauses uh oh yeah yeah it was
yeah Fidelity Clauses and people still
do these I discourage people from doing
them they're the two things that people
put in prenups that I discourage people
from putting in prenups but very often
people still put in prenups even with my
caveat is Fidelity Clauses and sunset
clauses
so Fidelity Clauses is
um I'm waving alimony I'm waving this
I'm waving that but if you cheat
I get a million bucks or I get this much
alimony or I get this amount and I know
the intention is to disincentivize the
person from cheating it's a deterrent to
have them cheat but all it really does
is just creates like an interesting
legal battle for lawyers like how did
you prove that they cheated or not all
right because uh what what yeah what
constitutes cheating also right right is
an emotional affair and Affair is oral
sex cheating is you know like what what
is and by the way how do you prove it
yeah like while I was in a hotel with
her but how do you prove that I had sex
with her you know like and it's it's
very very
um you're opening a can of worms with
that kind of a thing but people
sometimes still put them in
um and sunset Clauses Sunset Clauses is
if we're married X period of time this
goes away as if it never existed and why
is that a bad idea the same reason the
community property law in California is
a bad idea so the community property law
is after a certain number of years I
think it's seven
everything including your pre-marital
property all becomes marital property
and the idea of that was supposed to be
that if you've been married that number
of years like you're in enough of a
serious relationship now that everything
is one unit you're one person what it
actually does is creates a very
uncomfortable thought experiment that
people have to have at the six year mark
because you have to now the honeymoon's
kind of over you might have a kid or two
and you go okay wait a minute am I so
happy in this relationship
that I'm willing to take all of my
pre-marital assets and throw them in the
pot right now because if not I got six
months to get divorced yeah like and
that's not so like if you say to someone
like if you got married tomorrow
and then you found a company that's
worth a hundred million dollars
and under your prenup that's your
separate property
but there's a sunset Clause that says
that your prenup goes out the window in
15 years man at year 14 and six months
you gotta ask yourself some serious
questions about where's this
relationship going to be in five ten
years it's brilliant and that's why kids
you pay for a lawyer that's it we get
paid to see around corners you know I
get paid to be paranoid I tell people
that all the time